at the end of the second world war axis
borders were redrawn often as
compensation for occupation yugoslavia
got this from italy poland got this from
germany and the ussr gained all of this
one nation which had also pushed to gain
land from germany was the netherlands
which asks to be given all of these
lands in 1949. as you'll guess they got
very little they didn't get nothing they
were in fact given this tiny bit of land
here most of which they soon sold back
to germany in the 1960s but given how
badly damaged the netherlands was by the
second world war why weren't they given
more land so after germany was defeated
many countries wanted compensation from
their occupiers the netherlands was no
different and their demands were simple
give us cash lots of it unfortunately
for them the great powers had agreed at
the altar conference that there would be
no financial reparations mostly because
of what had happened last time that
germany was forced to pay such
reparations and for the dutch this meant
that the only way that they could get
something out of germany was by
animating land the proposals were simple
take as much as we can and kick out all
of the germans who live there internally
the dutch government had hoped to be
given all of this which included cologne
as well as important historical cities
like arkhan and munster there were a few
in the government that even pushed for
the annexation of lands around dortmund
and hamburg but this was seen as
unreasonable so what happened when they
put these ideas to the allied powers
they were laughed out of the room by all
except france this was because france
was also pushing for a somewhat
dismembered germany as such plan b the
dutch reduced their claims to this the
answer was also no and they came back
with the third offer of only taking this
it won't shock you to know that the
allies rejected this as well and by
allies i mean mostly the british you see
these lands were in the british zone of
occupation given that east germany had
been divided amongst the east and
blockaded many refugees these refugees
needed food and housing which was
difficult to build the dutch plan to
annex these lands and kick out all of
the germans living there would have
meant millions more refugees and less
places to house them yet for the dutch
the removal of the germans from the
netherlands were seen as vital to
national security because it meant that
germany would have less crowns to retake
these lands in the future the dutch were
pretty angry about this since it looked
like they were going to get nothing
which would make the government look
pretty weak however the allies did opt
to give some bits of land on the border
here to the dutch as a form of placation
it was occupied in mid-1949 and just
short of a decade later the west german
government came knocking many in the
dutch government wanted to keep the
lands out of principle but a good
working relationship with the new
democratic germany was seen as valuable
and also perhaps the netherlands could
use the land to trade for some of the
cash that they had wanted previously in
the end it was agreed that germany would
pay roughly 80 million dollars for the
return of the lands well most of it the
netherlands kept a tiny bit of land for
itself whilst the rest was transferred
back to west germany in 1963 meaning
after world war ii the dutch did get
some territorial concessions from
germany just not very much
i hope you enjoyed this episode and a
special thanks to my patrons james
bisonette kelly money maker sky
chappelle corso wolff jordan longley
adam stalter jerry lambda marcus arsenal
words about books podcast rod d martin
wyan hockey marvin castle spencer
lightfoot boogerly wiggly winston k wood
captain cydol common yoon gustav swan
daniel tobin mrset aaron the white
matthew shipley maggie patzkowski alex
schwinn corey turner anthony beckett
coppertone schwennin spinning three
plates the mcquapper and charles the
first